This course presumes no prior
knowledge of its Sabic Jack Matter.
That is to say,
you can take this course without having
done any political philosophy before.
The materials we're going to look at
in this course can be approached that a
number of levels of sophistication,
a indeed you could teach
an entire course on,
on just John Stewart mill or John Roles.
We'll call marks what Jeremy Bentham.
Um,
and that this means that some of you who
may have had or some prior acquaintance
with some of these tax will be able to
explore them in a different way from
newcomers. But the course
is designed, uh, as I said,
to be user friendly to people who
are doing this for the first time.
There are a few parts of the course
in which I make use of technical,
uh, notations or
diagrams. Now, it is true,
it's just a fact about human beings
that if you put a graph or a chart or a,
a curve up on a diagram,
there's certain paypal,
some subset of the population.
They get a knot in their stomach.
They start to feel nauseas and
their brain stops functioning.
I can totally relate to it because I'm
actually one of those people by this
position.
Uh,
and what I can tell you about our use
of charts and diagrams and notations in
this course is this simply shorthand
for people who find it useful.
But I will do nothing with,
um,
diagrams and charts that
I don't also do verbally.
So if you don't get it the one way
you'll be able to get it the other way.
Um,
there are plenty of seats down here and
they're also seats upstairs if you want.
Um, so you should never feel
intimidated, you know, as a,
as I said, for people who
find graphs and charts useful,
they're a form of shorthand. But obviously
if they intimidate somebody and they,
they make what's being said opaque,
then they're being south defeating a.
And as I said,
I will always walk verbally through
anything that I also do with charts and
diagrams. Secondly, related to that point,
um,
it's my commitment to you that this
is a course that's done from first
principles and everything's
explained from the ground up.
I might forget that contract some time
and use a term that you don't understand.
I might use a word like day ontological.
Okay.
And you'll sit down, you'll be
thinking, what does that mean?
And the high probabilities is
that if you don't know what it,
they're probably 70 other people in the
room who don't know what it means either.
And so if you put up your
hand and ask what it means
every you'll be doing that
was 69 people a favor, um,
because they wanted to know what it
means as well. So we shouldn't have any,
any situation in this course in which I'm
using some term that you don't and you
can't follow what I'm talking
about because you don't
understand what it means.
Um,
it is a rather embarrassing fact about
political philosophers that they don't
say in words of one syllable what can
be setting where words a five syllables.
But part of my job here is to reduce
them to words of one syllable, uh,
that is, um, to,
to take complex theoretical ideas and
make them loose it an intelligible to you.
And I say that as,
as a big part of what we're doing here.
So that your takeaway from this score,
it's three months ago,
three months from now.
Um,
we'll include feeling very comfortable
with the language of political philosophy
and the central, uh, terminology
in which it's conducted. So,
um,
hold my feet to the fire
on that if you need to,
if I use words you don't understand,
put up your hand and stop me.
I will from time to time throw out
questions and we'll have a microphone,
uh, that we can pass around so that, uh,
people can answer the questions. It's
one of the ways in which I gage, um,
how, how well the communication
between us is going.
Um,
so you should expect that
any other housekeeping matters before
I get into the substance of the course.
Good.
So this is a course about the
moral foundations of politics,
that moral foundations of
political argument and the
way in which we organize it
is to explore a number of
traditions of political theorizing.
And these are broadly grouped into
a bigger distinction that I make between
enlightenment and anti enlightenment
thinking.
That is to say we're going to start
off by looking at the enlightenment.
Now you might say, well,
what is the enlightenment?
How do you know when you trip over it?
And that is a subject I'm
going to get to uh, next,
uh, on Wednesday and Friday
because Friday, as you all know,
is going to be Mondays pluses
because of Martin Luther King.
Um,
but for right now I'll say
just dogmatically and I'll
elaborate for you later
that the enlightenment
revolved around two ideas.
The first is the idea of basing,
oh,
there is a politics on science,
not on religion, not on
tradition, not on superstition,
not on natural law,
but on science.
The enlightenment was born of an enormous
optimism about the possibilities of
science.
And in this course we
will look at enlightenment
theories that puts science at
the core of political argument.
The second main enlightenment idea is
the idea that individual freedom is the
most important political guard.
And so if you,
if you wanted to get the bumper
sticker version of the enlightenment,
a account of politics in it is how do
you scientifically design a society to
maximize individual freedom?
Now we're well within that,
we will look at three
enlightenment traditions.
We'll look at the utilitarian tradition,
the Marxist tradition and the
social contract tradition.
And, uh, again,
I'll just give you the one line version
now and then we're going to come back to
all of these, of course, in
much greater detail later.
The utilitarian tradition says that the
way in which you create a scientifically
organize society is you maximize the
greatest happiness of the greatest number.
This is the, the, uh,
slogan of utilitarianism.
Maximize the greatest happiness
of the greatest number.
You will find that huge disagreements
among utilitarians about how you measure
your happiness and how you maximize it
and how you know when you've maximized it
and so on.
But the utilitarians all agree that that's
the goal and that if you can do that,
you will do more to maximize
human freedom than anything else.
The Marxist tradition has a very
different theory of science.
What Marx called the science
of historical materialism.
But it too was based on this idea
that we can have impersonal scientific
principles that give us the right
answer for the Organization of society.
One of Mark's is famous wine liners.
Why's that?
We will eventually get to a world
in which politics is replaced by
administration,
implying that all forms of
moral disagreement we'll
have gone away because we
will have gotten the
technically the right answers.
And now the formulation of that same
idea actually comes from a different
enlightenment thinker who are
not going to read in this course,
David Hume who said if,
if all moral,
if all moral disagreements
were resolved, no, no,
uh,
political disagreements would remain.
So that's the idea of a scientific,
a solution to um,
what appear to be the moral
dilemmas that divide us.
So for marks, we'll see a very different
theory of science, but for him to,
he thinks that freedom is the most
important. Good. That might surprise you.
Most people think, well, march was
about equality. He was egalitarian.
You'll see that that's only true in a,
in a somewhat the rivet of sense because
in the end what it was important for
Marx was that people are equally free,
um,
that they are in a situation
of not being exploited. Uh,
and he too,
therefore it's an enlightenment thinker.
Then the social contract tradition says
that the way we get some scientific
theory of society is to think about
what agreement people would make if they
were designing society for the first time.
If society was going to be based on
a contract, what would it look like?
And this is what gives us
the right hands, uh, uh,
as to what is rational scientific
principles tell us how we should organize
society.
And it's a society,
a world in which people's freedom is
preserved because it's what they choose to
do.
Again,
as in these other
enlightened many traditions,
there's massive disagreement about who
makes the contract, how they make it,
um, what the content of
it would be. But it's,
it's the metaphor of a social contract
that shapes all reasoning about the way
in which you can organize
society scientifically in
order to preserve freedom.
So in the first two thirds of the course,
we're gonna work our way through
those three enlightenment traditions.
But every current has its undertow.
And even though the enlightenment
was this enormous Lee, uh,
energetic,
um,
and captivating tradition that really
starts in the 17th century and,
uh, get steam and gather
steam in the 18th century,
there was always resistance
to the enlightenment.
Both its preoccupation with science and
its view that individual freedom is the
most important guard.
And so after we've done
looking at the enlightenment,
we're gonna look at anti
enlightenment thinking, um,
and the tradition that resists the idea
that there are scientific principles
around which society can be organized
and resist the idea that the freedom of
the individual is the most important.
Good.
And we'll explore that tradition.
And then in the last part of the course,
we will turn to the democratic tradition,
which tries,
at least in the way I
will present this to you,
to reconcile the anti enlightened
men critique of the enlightenment,
uh,
with those elements of the enlightenment
that survive the Anti Enlightenment
Critique, if you see what I'm saying.
So democracy becomes the resolution,
uh, at least in the way I'll
describe democracy in this course,
thereby hangs. And now the tail light
I want to tell you about this course.
The course is a introductory and
presented in a user friendly way to to no
commas, but it also is an argument
that is, I'm presenting an argument,
a point of view, which some of
you will be, I'm persuaded by,
and that is totally fine.
The idea is not to make you think what
I think or what your teaching assistant.
Thanks.
It's rare that to make you understand the
logic underlying your own views better
than you have before and
perhaps see the appeal of used,
you have hit it two rejected more
clearly than you have before.
So it's the idea is to
enhance the sophistication
of your own understanding of
politics,
not to have your parrot,
my views or teaching follows
views or anybody else's views. Um,
it's rare that too,
to understand the nature of your own
views and how they might connect a or live
intention with the views of others.
One thing you're going to find,
I should also say just as a,
as a matter of truth in advertising,
we're going to look at a number of what
I would call architectonic theories of
politics. That theories that
try to give the whole answer.
This is, you know, Jeremy Bentham,
this is his scientific theory.
These are all the pieces.
These are how they,
this is how they fit together and this
is what it means for the organization of
schools and prisons and all
amounts and all the rest of it.
He's got an architect on a theory of
the whole thing, John Roles as well.
You'll see an architectonic theory of the
whole thing. One of the things you're,
one of the takeaway points of this course
is going to be that architect tonic
theories fail that there no,
there is no silver bullet.
You're not gonna find a takeaway,
um,
set of propositions that you can
plaster on to future political dilemmas.
What you're going to find instead,
I think what's going to
help you in this course,
what's going to be the useful takeaway,
uh,
is rather small and medium sized insights.
You're going to find things to put in
your conceptual bag of tricks and take and
use elsewhere and they're going to be
very helpful to you in analyzing a whole
variety of problems.
I think if you talk to other
students have taken this course,
that tends to be the most useful,
uh,
the most useful takeaway,
that you get that you'll find when
somebody brings up an argument,
say about what people are entitled to.
You'll have a whole series of questions
you would ask about that argument that
you wouldn't have asked if
you hadn't taken the scores.
So you'll find a lot of,
um,
small and medium sized bits and pieces
that you can take and use in other
contexts,
but you're not gonna find it a one size
fits all answer to the basic dilemmas of
politics.
Um,
let me say one other thing about
this course is being an argument. Um,
uh, that, uh,
the arguments presented from
a particular point of view.
You might say, well, you know,
looking through the syllabus,
hmm,
this guy is pretty arrogant.
I mean, here we have,
you know, John Locke, John
stood male, Jeremy Bentham,
and he's got his own,
some of his own work here on the syllabus.
Who does he think he is? You know, I mean,
these are the greats of the tradition
and he's putting his own work here.
It takes a lot of Chutzpah to do that.
And let me tell you a little vignette
that I think will give you the spirit in
which my work is on the syllabus.
When I was an undergraduate,
there was a great con scholar
called Stefan Karna, uh,
who was here in the Yale philosophy
department for many years.
And also taught at the
University of Bristol in England.
And I attended his lectures on can't and
he stood up and the very first lecture,
and he said,
con was a great philosopher.
What?
I am a minor philosopher,
but with me,
you have the advantage that I am alive
now. This is the spirit in which, uh,
my work is that it's not remotely
intended to be a suggestion that 200 years
from now or 300 years from now, people
will be reading it or that it stands, uh,
on a par with the work that,
um,
the classic works of the tradition.
But one of our agendas in the scores is
not just to get you up to speed in the
great texts of these different traditions,
but to give you some sense of
how people who currently do this,
we're living argue about these ideas.
Um,
so in each one of the five
traditions that we look at,
we're going to begin with
a classic formulation.
So Jeremy Bentham is the locus
classicus of classical utilitarianism.
He's a major formative
statement of that view.
So we'll start with Bentham,
but then we will bring
utilitarianism up to the present day.
We will explore how diff,
how the utilitarian traditional
evolved since the 18th century.
And we will bring you up to contemporary
considerations about utilitarianism,
what people argue about in the journals
today and the book literature and so on.
Um,
likewise with Marxism,
we'll start with Marx and Engels
themselves and then bring you up to
contemporary debates about
Marxism social contract tradition.
We'll start with John Locke,
a WHO's famously formulated the social
contract idea in the 17th century,
but we'll bring it up to modern contract.
There were a slight Robic Nozick and,
and John Rawls,
the Anti Enlightenment tradition.
We go back to Edmund Burke, the great, uh,
anti enlightenment thinker of the,
an opponent of the French revolution.
But we'll bring anti
enlightenment thinking up to
contemporary thinkers like a
Alisdair Macintyre.
And finally with the democratic tradition,
we'll go back to the,
the, uh, federalist papers,
which is what, uh, in,
in Wa in many ways,
one of the most important statements
of what's at issue with democratic
principles,
if not a defense of democracy.
Will see later and bring that up to the
contemporary literature on democracy,
which is where my own, uh,
thinking comes in. But, uh,
as I say,
you should,
you should remember Stefan
Carnez admonition that
you're getting the benefit of
the fact that I happened to be around
in the first decade of the 21st century.
Not that I'm
attempting to put myself
on that kind of a pedestal.
Now
I want to say a few more
general things about the course,
just to give you a sense of the flavor
of what we do here. You might say, well,
what is distinctive about this course
as compared with other introductory
political theory and political philosophy
courses that you could take around
here?
And I think there are four senses
in which this course is distinctive,
not necessarily better, but just
different. Uh, and so the, the, the,
you can give you some sense of,
uh,
what it is that you would be
letting yourself in for here.
The first is what I've just mentioned,
that with each of these five traditions,
we really are going to take,
take them from a classical formulation,
um,
up to contemporary discussions.
So you'll have a at least working sense
of how these traditions have evolved
over the course of two or 300 years
and what form debates about them today.
Take
the second is that this course has really
garn and mix the theoretical with the
applied.
We're going to look at first principles.
I use the term foundations advisedly
in the title of the course there.
Uh,
it's something of a loaded term in
that there are some people who think,
uh,
we should do political philosophy without
foundations and I'll have something to
say about those arguments
later in the course. But we,
I do want to signal with that term,
we will be interested in
foundational questions.
The most basic questions
you can ask about politic.
But we will never limit our intention
to those questions. We will,
we will work these doctrines through
a huge array of contemporary problems
ranging
from,
um,
abortion to affirmative action
to the death penalty to,
um,
all kinds of other things that are
of concern to you as we go through.
So it's very much a part of what we do
in this course is to look at how these
doctrines actually play out on the ground.
Um,
so we'd go back and forth from particular
examples to general arguments and
backed in particular examples
a lot in this course. Um,
and in that sense it's,
it's more of a course I'd say in applied
political philosophy than many courses
one might take, um, here or elsewhere.
A third,
the distinctive feature of the course is
that I'm going to organize it centrally
around one question,
which seems to me at the end of the day,
to be the most important
question of politics.
And that is a question that I put in the
first sentence of the syllabus there.
When do governments deserve our allegiance
and when should they be denied it?
Okay.
When and under what conditions
should we obey the government?
When are we free to disobey
the government and when my,
we even have an obligation
to oppose the government.
Another way, if you want to translate
this into the jargon of political theory,
it is what is it that makes
governments legitimate?
What is the basis for legitimate
government that is going to be the core
organizing idea or question with
which we're going to interrogate these
different traditions that we
examine utilitarian Marxists,
social contract, anti enlightenment
and democratic traditions.
We we're going to look at how does each
one of those traditions and said the
most basic questions about
the legitimacy of the state.
Um, it's, as I say,
I think it's ultimately the most
important question in politics.
It's not the only question in politics.
It's not the only way to organize
a course in political philosophy,
but it is the way in which
we'll organize this course.
We will focus our question on
legitimacy and that'll be the,
it'll provide the template for
comparing across these traditions,
right?
We will,
we will be looking at how utilitarians
or social contract theorist or democratic
theorists look at this basic question
of what it is that makes governments
legitimate,
um,
how we know that when we fall over
it and what we should do about it.
Okay,
so that's the third sense in
which the course is distinctive.
And the fourth one I
want to mention is that
we're going to go back and forward
between two modes of analysis,
which for want of better terms,
I call internal and external,
and I may explain what
I mean by those terms.
When you look at an argument that somebody
puts forward and you look at it in a
way that I'm describing as internal,
what you're basically saying is,
does it make sense?
Is it persuasive?
Are the premises plausible?
Do the conclusions
follow from the premises?
Are there contradictions
in what the person's saying
this at all? Hang together?
Should I believe it?
That is it a good argument?
That's what internal analysis is about.
Okay.
External analysis is looking at the
argument as a causal force in the world.
What
social and political arrangements is
this argument used to justify or what
social and political arrangement
is it used to attack?
How does this operate as a political
ideology in the world out there?
What effects does it have
if I embraced this argument?
So it's not a question about whether or
not it's a good argument or you should
believe it,
but a question about how this argument
is efficacious in the world because there
could be terrible arguments that are
nonetheless very efficacious in the world,
right?
And there might be very good arguments
that nobody takes seriously and in day to
day politics.
And one of the great aspirations of the
enlightenment is to produce arguments
that both make good analytical
and philosophical sense
on the one hand and can
be influential in the world on the other.
But those things don't
necessarily go together.
And we're going to ask
a question why in all,
in the context of exploring all
of these traditions, why is that?
If there are good arguments that
are not efficacious, why that is?
Why is it if they're a bad
arguments that are efficacious,
why that is? Um, but in
any case, we're going to,
even if we can't answer that why question,
which is a very hard question to answer,
we're going to look at these, these,
these arguments and these traditions
both internally and externally.
You're going to look at them as arguments
and you're going to look at them as
ideologies, as, um,
systems of thought that,
that get traffic then in
the political world. And,
um,
I think that that is another feature of
this course that differentiates it from
other introductory
political theory courses.
So I think that gives you something of
a flavor of what is distinctive in what
we do here.
Any questions about any of that?
If any of it's puzzling to you,
it's probably puzzling to somebody else.
So, in the spirit of, um,
getting us going,
we're going to start with a,
a real world problem.
We're going to start with
the problem of ad off Eichmann who
was a lieutenant colonel in the,
in Nazi Germany,
who was responsible for organizing the
shipment of Jews to Nazi death camps.
And
at the end of the war,
um,
he was captured along with a lot
of other former Nazis and he was
inadvertently released.
They didn't realize that
he was a significant player
in the organization of the
so called final solution of the Jews.
And they,
they released him and he escaped.
And like many other
former Nazis who escape,
he went to Argentina and he
lived under an assumed name, uh,
for many years until the late 1950s
when the Israeli secret service,
the Mossad figured out that he was
there and figured out who he was.
And they sent a group of people who,
uh,
essentially commandos who captured him,
spirited him out of Argentina,
took him to Israel where they
brought back the death penalty,
which had not existed at
that time in Israeli law.
Tried him for crimes against humanity,
which is the same concept that had been
employed at the Nuremberg trials, uh,
off his cohort,
um,
after world war two in the late 1940
is crimes against humanity and crimes
against the Jewish people.
And they executed him.
And at that time, young political
theorists, not particularly well known,
um,
called Hannah aren't covered.
The trial for the New Yorker magazine
in a series of articles which was
subsequently published as a book
called Eichmann in Jerusalem,
which is what I'm having you
read full Wednesday's class
and
we're going to use this Eichmann problem
as a way into the central conundrum of
the course,
which I said is what,
what is it that gives state's
legitimate legitimacy?
When should we obey the government?
Why don't we free not to and
when should we have perhaps, uh,
even be obliged to oppose the government?
Cause this problem was thrown into
sharp relief by the conduct of Eichmann
during World War Two.
And I want you think about
two questions
while you'd read this,
this,
which is essentially this book is
essentially a compilation of [inaudible],
a New Yorker articles.
The first is IPI.
What I want you to do is to think
about what the two things are that make
you most uncomfortable about this man
who you'll get to know quite
well for reading this book.
What is it about him that is unnerving?
What is it that makes your
flesh crawl about this guy?
What are the two things that are
the most appalling about him?
And then the other question I want
you to address is the second one.
What two things make you
most uncomfortable about
the events surrounding his apprehension
and his child and his execution in
Israel.
Those are your reading
questions for [inaudible]
and write them down and bring him
with you to class on Wednesday.
Let me just say one other thing.
I see we,
we were actually got five extra
minutes here. Generally speaking,
we have a lot to cover. We
will stick to the syllabus. Uh,
this course runs exactly as
described in the syllabus,
but we don't have a lot of,
uh,
there's not a lot of dead time and it's
really important to me that we be able
to start right on the button.
Um,
yeah.
And I will, I will not run over. I
will always finish at 10 20 at 1120.
I know we pay by by the places to get to,
but it's really important that you're
trying to get here ready to go,
because you know, if it's, if it's
20 of 11 before we really get going,
um, it doesn't leave a lot of time
to cover what I want to cover.
And, um, so my, I, I promise to you,
I will not run over, but
please, uh, do everybody,
including yourselves a favor
by trying to get here, uh,
as promptly as you can so
that we can start. Okay.
Uh, we'll look forward to
seeing you on Wednesday.